so with the beginning those were the
talkies right is that well no i want to
go back
i want to go way before the talkies i
want to go to the silence the silence
yeah i i want to go to sorry i meant i'm
forgiving it
i want to go back to sort of george
mandias
prancing around there's a little studio
in paris
making those imaginary kind of movies
that
martin scorsese sort of look back on
with fondness and hugo
um you know um what year was this sorry
what
what year was uh the first silent film
well
first island film was 1895 uh and uh
1895 a couple of filmmakers the lumiere
brothers who were the
sons of a prominent french film
company kind of like kodak
hit on a way to use a small
camera to shoot film to develop it and
to project it
they call it the cinematograph and in
1895 they rented some space
in a cafe in paris
and exhibited it to train coming up
people walking in a factory some kids
beside a lake
and people were a gog because they'd
never seen anything like that
one of the first people who sat in on
the movie was a magician
named george madis he's a stage magician
he saw the film and said my god
what a fantastic aid that would be for
storytelling in movies for making magic
and he particularly sort of figured that
when
he got himself a camera went out on the
street
and in the middle of shooting the camera
jammed he then reloaded
he shot again and suddenly what had been
a bus
turned into magically a hearse and
suddenly said oh my goodness
uh here is a new world here's a new way
to tell stories
and i can do it with this picture stuff
so i'm saying yeah
that going all the way back is a great
place to begin
you